The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JOHN ESSIGMANN: Let's
Look at Storyboard 17,
Panel A. So far in 5.07,
we've looked in detail
at carbohydrate
catabolism, we've
seen that the
complete catabolism
of a molecule of glucose by
way of glycolysis, pyruvate,
dehydrogenase, and
the TCA cycle results
in the generation of about
36 to 38 molecules of ATP.
At this point,
we're going to turn
to catabolism of another
metabolic fuel, lipids.
As we'll see
lipids, because they
contain more energy per
gram, because they're
more highly reduced
than carbohydrates,
will produce much
more ATP pundit weight
than carbohydrates.
For example, if we were to
metabolize hexanoic acid,
the six carbon hydrocarbon,
the same number of carbons
as glucose, we'd get
over 50 ATPs rather than
about 35 ATPs per
molecule, which
we would have got from glucose.
Now let's look at
Panel B. Lipids
have many roles in
biological systems.
The first that will be
relevant to this lecture
is that there are
primary energy reserve.
In fact about 80% of our stored
energy is in the form of lipid.
Second, as JoAnne
taught us, lipids
are key components of
biological membranes,
and thus, they
contribute in a major way
to the
compartmentalisation that's
critical for normal
biological functions.
And the third role is that some
lipids are signaling molecules.
The one I've pictured
here is Estradiol.
While Estradiol may not
look like a typical lipid
it actually is.
Indeed, it's made by a lipid
biosynthetic pathway that
starts with Acetyl
Coenzyme A. And we'll
see later that Acetyl
CoA also serves
as the precursor for the
canonical lipid fatty acid.
Fatty acids are
the classic lipid.
They're hydrocarbon chains that
are fully saturated or contain
a small number of double
bonds and sometimes branches.
Sometimes the fatty acid
moiety is esterified
to the backbone of glycerol.
If you have three fatty acids
on a glycerol backbone, one
to each of the
hydroxyl groups, that's
called a triacylglyceride.
That's our primary
storage form of energy.
With phospholipids, one
of the hydroxyl groups
of the glycerol backbone is
esterified to either phosphate
or some kind of
decorated phosphate
where the decoration could be
a sugar or some other moiety.
As was seen in JoAnne's
lecture's, phospholipids
are the key building blocks
of biological membrane.
Now take a look at Panel
D. The rest of this lecture
will deal with the details of
how fatty acids are broken down
to carbon dioxide with the
intermediate production
of reducing equivalents in
the form of NADH and FADH-2
and ultimately energy
equivalence in the form of ATP.
Cells can acquire
lipids directly
from the blood where typically
they're transported by albumin.
They can come directly from
our diet or from other organs
or from breakdown
of triacylglycerides
within our cells.
We're going to be
looking at four
steps in fatty acid catabolism.
The first step involves the
appearance of the fatty acid
in the cytoplasm of the cell.
The fatty acid can come
in either from breakdown
of a triacylglyceride
stored in the cytoplasm,
or the fatty acid could
appear from transport
across the membrane
from the blood.
In the cytoplasm,
the fatty acid,
which is technically
a carboxylic acid,
will be thioesterified to
form a fatty Acyl Coenzyme A.
The second step of
fatty acid catabolism
involves the transport of the
fatty Acyl Coenzyme A ester
into the mitochondrion,
which is the site
of fatty acid oxidation.
The third step in
fatty acid catabolism
involves the actual
oxidation process itself.
The series of reactions
is called beta oxidation.
Beta oxidation results
in the conversion
of the carboxylic acid starting
material to Acetyl Coenzyme A.
There can be several
fates to the Acetyl
CoA produced by beta oxidation.
But the one we're
going to be looking at
is its entry into the TCA
cycle, where the Acetyl CoA is
metabolized to carbon dioxide
with the generation of reducing
equivalents.
Those reduced electron
carriers have the potential
to be converted into energy
currency in the form of ATP.
The fourth topic or
stage in fatty acid
catabolism that we'll deal with
concerns specialized endings
of the catabolic pathway.
The first problem that
we'll look at concerns
the fact that some fatty acids
have an odd number of carbons
in them, whereas the classical
fatty acid beta oxidation
system was primarily designed
to process fatty acids with even
numbers of carbon units.
The second problem
that we'll look
at as an ending of
fatty acid oxidation
concerns the fact that some
of the fatty acids in our diet
have a double bond that is
either in the wrong stereo
chemistry or is
in the wrong place
to enable easy metabolism.
Nature has worked out ways
to reposition the double bond
to facilitate the
entry of the molecule
into classical beta
oxidation schemes.
Let's look now at
Panel E. The first step
in fatty acid catabolism
involves thioesterification
of the carboxylate
residue of the fatty acid.
We're going to see in
a couple of minutes
that placing a Coenzyme A
moiety on the carboxylate
is going to enable chemistry
at the beta carbon.
Without the Coenzyme A group,
chemistry at the beta carbon
would be impossible.
The enzyme involved is
called Fatty Acyl Coenzyme
A synthetase, sometimes
called ligase.
And it additionally goes by the
more common name Thiokinase.
This enzyme uses
ATP to adenalate
the carboxalate residue.
And then it allows Coenzyme
A to replace the AMP residue
with the resulting product
being a fatty Acyl Coenzyme
A. This reaction happens in
the cytoplasm of the cell.
Beta oxidation however,
is going to occur
in the mitochondrial matrix.
So we have to find a way to get
this fatty Acetyl Coenzyme A
into the mitochondrial matrix.
Let's go now to Storyboard
18, Panel A. Panel A
shows the cytoplasm, the
mitochondrial outer membrane,
the intermembrane space,
the inner membrane,
and the mitochondrial matrix.
As I just said,
the matrix is going
to be the site at which
beta oxidation occurs.
The intermembrane space
contains a small alcohol
called Carnitine.
And the mitochondrial
outer membrane
contains an enzyme called
Carnitine Acyl Transferase I
or CAT-I.
CAT-I removes the Acyl group
from the Fatty Acyl Coenzyme
A in the cytoplasm
and transfers it
to the alcoholic
residue in the center
of the carnitine
molecule forming
an ester of the fatty
acid with carnitine.
This ester is
delivered to CAT-II,
which is embedded in the inner
membrane on the matrix side.
CAT-II will then transfer
the Acyl functionality
to a Coenzyme A, restoring the
fatty Acyl Coenzyme A molecule.
Thus, CAT-I and CAT-II
working in a concerted way,
result in the effective transfer
of a fatty Acyl Coenzyme A
from the cytoplasm into
the mitochondrial matrix,
the site of beta oxidation,
which will be our next step.
Let's now look at Panel B.
This panel shows an inset
with the mitochondrial inner
membrane, the electron transfer
complex, and ETFP, the
electron transferring
flavor protein, which
is going to be the entry
point of electrons from the
initial step of oxidation
of the Fatty Acyl CoA into
the electron transport chain.
We also see in this
panel, the fatty acid
polmitate the C-16 Straight
Chain Carboxylic Acid.
The hydrogen beta to
the Coenzyme A ester
is relatively acidic,
therefore this hydrogen
will be taken off
to form an alkene.
And the hydride
will be transferred
from the beta carbon, the
third carbon from the right.
Those electrons are
transferred to a flavin
in the electron transferring
flavor protein, ETFP.
Eventually, those electrons
are transferred to Coenzyme Q
to form the reduced form of
Coenzyme Q. Those electrons
then travel along through
the electron transport chain.
The Organic product
of this reaction
is a trans enoyl Coenzyme A.
Now let's take a look at
Panel C. In the next step,
water is added to the 3 Carbon
of the enoyl Coenzyme A.
Resulting product is a 3
Hydroxy Fatty Acyl Coenzyme
A. We've seen oxidation of
alcohols that looks something
like this many times.
For example, malate
being oxidized by malate
dehydrogenase to oxaloacetate.
And as we have seen
before, the hydroxyl group
is converted to a
keto functionality.
Hydride transfer goes
to NAD+ to form NADH.
The enzyme that
does this conversion
is 3 Hydroxy Fatty Acyl
Coenzyme A Dehydrogenase.
At this point, we have generated
one FADH-2 and one NADH
in the overall process of
the beta oxidation scheme.
The 3 Keto Acyl
Coenzyme A is now
set up to release a first
molecule of Acetyl Coenzyme
A. The enzyme beta ketothiolase
has a cystine on it.
The thiol of the
cystine will attack
the carbon that
has the keto group
and release Acetyl
Coenzyme A. The residue is
a thioester in which
the residual 14
carbons of the polmitate
that we started with
are now connected to
beta-ketothiolase.
Lastly, beta-ketothiolase
will transfer this residual 14
carbons to a
Coenzyme A molecule,
forming the Fatty
Acyl Coenzyme A
that will be 14
carbons long, that is,
it's two carbons shorter than
the 16 carbons of polmitate
that we started with.
Overall, this process is
called beta oxidation.
The system is now set up
to allow the 14 carbon
molecule to go to 12 to 10
and so on, until the entire 16
carbon hydrocarbon has
been reduced through seven
rounds of beta oxidation to
eight molecules of Acetyl
Coenzyme A. If these eight
molecules of Acetyl CoA
are further oxidized
by the TCA cycle,
you'll get 96 ATP molecules.
And of course, along the way,
in each round of beta oxidation,
you will also produce
seven FADH-2s.
The seven FADH-2s will be
converted into 14 ATPs.
You will also get
seven NADHs, and they
will be converted into 21 ATPs.
So the full conversion of the
16 carbon hydrocarbon polmitate
will result in a
total of 131 ATPs.
In order to put together
a full balance sheet,
however, keep in
mind that we needed
to use several ATPs early
in the process in order
to prime the system.
That is Fatty Acyl Coenzyme A
synthetase used 2 high energy
phosphate bonds in order
to prime the fatty acid
for production of the
Coenzyme A intermediate
that's necessary
for beta oxidation.